magnets and [ __ ] we're talking about
whoa whoa you look like a sign of
borderline personality he's like you
love him and then you hate them the
exact same minute right and we were at
his supposed favorite barber shop we
went to the reason NASA always sure the
picture yeah so today this is what
happened this is what happened earlier
so we go to his barber shop that he's
been go he he that he insists on going
to even I don't think that they have the
best bar it looks like Justin Bieber but
like when he was first discovered was
like bullier we 11 that you [ __ ] and
so he goes dinner with it he goes into
the barbershop with a good attitude he's
happy and skipping yeah you know and and
then yeah he has a smoothie in his hand
that he wants to throw away and the
lady's like oh he has a smoothie in us
and he wants to throw it away so she a
trash can
that's not a really a trash can but it's
a trash can he throws it away and then
he gets yelled at by some what wasn't an
umbrella stand no it was one of those it
was for hair it was just for hair I mean
that's do it in there right and she
yells at me from across the counter is
she Asian Armenian she wasn't she wasn't
even a hairdresser or a barber he was
just very like upfront as soon as she
yelled at me I got out of here I hate I
hate everything about today
I heat completely crumbles right then
and there because she made me look like
a fool barber looks at me he picked up
he puts his hand back into the hair
trash again he began with his smoothie
another piece of trash and some hair now
is it's like all over I
I threw a crash that I didn't throw in
there yeah panicking I'm like I don't
know where to go
I'm here stuck a little my hands yeah oh
so you guys left no I got this [ __ ]
wait why don't you so what did you do
he's such a [ __ ] spineless bastard he
was getting the haircut and I was seeing
this lady just basically butcher my hair
butcher is [ __ ] guarantee why why are
you not even on saying anything yeah I
have this you know just this grimace on
my face he's like this what did I not
tell her what you wanted I
he said kpop Google meat oh no its Lobos
you google me baby Google me that looks
kind of Cape I could see that being kpop
but like a 14 year old oh you want me to
send you that picture yes he goes he's
not saying anything to this girl who's
butchering his hair like he could just
see it in his eyebrows and he's these
pissed he's sweating and yeah looking at
me like this
so finally I step in and I say hey
sweetie is that what you wanted because
that's a bowl cut yeah and then she was
like no I'm not done okay she was new
you could tell she was trembling atolan
oh maybe she was a fan no could have
been definitely not a fan maybe she was
the opposite of a fan maybe she hates
you
[Music]